the 2009 NBA draft features some of the
better players of the 2010s but let's go
back in time and redraft it to see how
it should have turned out starting out
the number one overall pick the Clippers
take Stephen Curry instead of Blake
Griffin Blake was a staple for Lob City
but glimpses of stuff became stuff easy
choice for Clipper Nation the Grizzlies
take James Harden at number two instead
of haseem to be knowing the beard will
become a league MVP would have
brightened the future for the grit and
grind Grizzlies that means the Thunder
will pick up Blake Griffin at the number
three spot forming a new big three
featuring Kevin Durant Russell Westbrook
and now blade Griffin Griffin didn't
play his rookie season but that Trio
would have been hard to stop in the open
court the King School Drew holiday with
the number 4 overall pick over Tyrique
Evans pairing the elite two-way ability
of holiday and Kevin Martin would have
given the Kings a scary good bad Court
Duo wrapping up the top five the Wolves
select DeMar DeRozan instead of Ricky
Rubio a mid-range Assassin from day one
DeRozan gives the T wolves a bucket
getter and a future six-time All-Star to
kick-start their rebuild but we gotta
know what do you think about our 2009
NBA redraft let us know in the comment
section